are you taking your per what you doing
with your purse this woman in the front
row is what are you doing you okay
everything we're just putting are you
getting comfortable okay I can hold the
purse for you if you want and do we look
after this woman's purse during the show
what she what she was probably doing was
she was holding on to it cuz she didn't
trust you and then she thought you know
what I'm being silly yeah she put it
down and then I turned out to be an
Incred that's good
thank you I think he looks really good I
want your watch right there I should
start doing that at the top of every
show give me that I like that give me
that you'll get that back in two weeks
it's a standard policy you don't want to
talk about this college cheating scandal
you're keeping up with this aren't you
this thing's insane
famous and wealthy parents paid bribes
they hired people to cheat on tests to
get their kids into elite colleges I
just it's it since the whole thing as
nuts I said to the guy holding the purse
[Laughter]
my kids are going to be patients in here
it is all set know the latest is will
you all know this Felicity Huffman and
Lori Loughlin are both under indictment
yes so it turns out actresses over 40
can get arrested in this town City thank
you everybody
medela is a 36 year old SAT Proctor is
the one who's being accused of taking
tasks for the students he took all the
tasks now on the bright side the man got
into Stanford Dartmouth and MIT so now
one of the people arrested yesterday was
the coach of Stanford sailing team yeah
he was charged with bribery and
pretending that sailing is a sport Helin
right sure sure
what's that thing where they lean way
over the side of the boats right and
think about themselves right
I got word you're a creep why were you
hanging on to it ma'am I'm sorry that's
not what he did I can have it what you
mean I can have this thing no no don't
encourage this kind of behavior that's a
bad thing
no no you keep it I want you to have
that we need to know it can feels like
there is something in there I don't want
to know but it just feels like yeah